For the cube root of 40, we have 2 times this cube root of 5. For the fourth
root of 48, we have 2 times the fourth root of 3, and for the fourth root of
64, we had 2 times the fourth root of 4. And finally, for our last answer,
we'll have 5 times the cube root of 20. Fantastic work for getting at least of
those correct. These were pretty tough. For the first one, we can rewrite 40 as
eight times five. Eight is the same thing as two cube so now we have a perfect
cube or a factor that appears three times within our radical. We can use the
product rule to split this radical up into the product of two radicals. We know
that a cubed root undoes a cubed power. So we're really left with just 2 here.
This also goes in line with our thinking, a power divided by root. 3 divided 3
equals 1 so we just have 2 to the 1. We can't simplify the 5 so that stays
inside of its cubed root and we have that multiplied on the end with our
answer. 2 times the cube root of 5. For the fourth root of 48, we split up 48
into 16 times 3. We rewrite 16 as 2 to the 4th and then we can take the fourth
root up to the fourth. The root undoes the fourth power. We leave the 3 inside
of the fourth root since we don't have four factors of 3, we just have one of
them. So our final answer is 2 times the fourth root of 3. We use a similar
method for finding the fourth root of 64. We rewrite 64 as 16 times 4. Take the
4th root of 2 to the 4th which leaves us with 2 times the 4th root of 4. For
our last one we split up 2,500 into 25 times 100, 25 equals 5 squared and 100
equals 5 times 20. We do this step so that way we can get three factors of 5
together. We know that the cube root of phi cubed is just 5. 20 is not a
prefect cube since the factors of 20 are 2, 2, and 5. There's not three factors
that repeat. This means 20 stays inside of our cubed root, and we are left with
our final answer. 5 times the cube root of 20.